Slovenia
where the forces of nature
have crafted rich landscapes primed for adventure.
Snowy peaks,
rolling hills,
pristine rivers
and steep cliffs
invite us to play.
In winter, these glacier carved
limestone mountains lure the adventurous
as they have for centuries.
By summer,
alpine ridges and meadows emerge.
Leading us along high trails
and through hidden valleys.
Mineral rich rivers
with challenging rapids
carve down through the topography.
A landscape
filled with old growth forests,
covering the slopes of the green hills.
High above, karst cliffs and caves
call out to those
who wish to brave the fight
against gravity.
Through the seasons,
these forces continue to work,
always shaping this unique outdoor playground.